pita
pita the people for the ethical
treatment of animals
an ironically named group because they
actually kill a lot of animals they are
involved in the killing of animals but
that's
neither here nor there because there
aren't enough people to take care of
them anyway neither here nor there at
least for this ad the people for the
ethical treatment of animals are i just
put out a video
the video was trying to persuade people
that if you go vegan you'll have a
better sex life it's better for your you
know blood flow or whatever and so the
video
involved i mean if you're you know we've
only got about a minute and a half left
here so if you've got
if you've got young children watching
listening is fine but watching uh maybe
close their eyes for a second
the it's a video
of people molesting fruit
take a listen
that says want to spice things up in the
bedroom there's people with like a kiwi
and a pepper chili peppers will have you
hot and heavy in no time the squirt of
oj can increase blood flow to important
organs
i'm going to look away from this get a
load of the zinc to increase your libido
avocados well this is disgusting we'll
give you the stamina to keep going go
vegan your partner will thank you
[Music]
like molesting a cantaloupe now someone
lay this just stop it stop it stop it
turn it off
this uh
this is the values that we're looking at
now first of all it's not very
persuasive to me
when we're told to adopt the you know
adopt our ethical system
and we're being told that by people who
are molesting fruit i don't that doesn't
seem like i want to adopt their ethical
system but this is a lot this actually
has to do with the political strategy of
the left what the left is doing they
always make these jokes like well if you
oppose our reviews you probably don't
have enough sex you're an incel or you
have small genitalia or you don't get
you pick up enough chicks or you don't
or you're not i don't know whatever it's
all like it always comes down to sex and
the reason they do this
is because their view of liberty is one
of of licentiousness and it just comes
down to lust and you know
whoever you can sleep with and just
doing a bunch of weird sex stuff to
appease your own appetites that's their
view i mean that's what they do they
enslave people by
by enslaving them to their own lusts and
getting them out of their rational mind
so that they can think that a video of
someone molesting fruit is somehow
persuasive i'm so glad you like that
clip but hold up i need your help on
something
sometimes you may have heard about this
the social media
companies the they don't
they don't love what we say okay and so
one way that we fight back against
censorship is making sure that people
have access to the direct stream the
audio podcast okay you can get that at
apple podcast spot if i stitch your
google play wherever you get your
podcasts just type in the michael
knowles show subscribe there maybe you
listen there maybe you watch it on
youtube maybe i don't know whatever you
want to do subscribe there make sure you
got access
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]